hey guys it's benefit to the G from GE
trekker here and today we're going to
talk about the BG s versus the dragon
Warhammer and its recent update with the
band o Scott sword having its back
buffed to a 50/50 percent meaning you
can spec it twice in a row with the
update there was speculation that this
would affect the dragon Warhammer
negatively because their effects were
quote-unquote
similar or some players falsely
believing that they were the exact same
so if we look at another post over here
this was before the update came around
wait a minute okay yeah this is I just I
saw this date I got a little confused
but we can see that this post came in I
don't want to go to metrics okay so we
can see this post came out on October
10th 2017 so not too long ago and this
guy is saying I believe the Bannos gods
what buff would greatly devalue the
dragon Warhammer due to the having the
same effects the BG s is very plentiful
in the market while the dragon or
hammers are super rare to get drop rate
one thousand one in five thousand verses
one and five hundred and eight I feel
this is very unfair to the updates to
people who obtained the dragon armor
through so much hard work just to be
crushed by this single update and then
people have posted on the on the thread
mentioning that they're not the exact
same and so he made another edit saying
another thing I realized is that the bgs
would most let me surpassed the AGS as
being the preferable PK and godsword
b gs this special attack has a 21% buff
and reduces all combat stats week of
what you hit
whereas a GS special has a 30th and 0.5%
damage buff but it's harder to obtain
them the beaches this could also have a
dramatic effect on the aegis any
thoughts no I don't have the a GS page
up so let me get that one up right now
so
talk about that one just a little bit
not too much but first first let's cover
the band OSCON sources the ages so if we
look at their special attacks vandals
God's our special attack war strike
double is the accuracy and inflicts 21
percent more damage draining all of the
opponent's stats equivalent though to
the amount of damage done okay and it
wasn't 50% before but now it is so
that's a key factor there the key factor
there is that it's dependent upon the
amount of damage done that reduces the
the opponent's stats okay so keep that
in mind now look at the dragon Weimer
real quick the special attack for the
dragon Warhammer has a special tech
smash which deals 50% more damage while
lowering the targets defense current
defense level by 30% on a hit other than
zero
it has to no damage even if it is a
successful hit rolls a zero it does not
work when used against Tecton it will
reduce 5% of his damage if it fails the
hit this attack can choose 50% of the
players
special attack okay so this one just
reduces its current defense level but by
30% and it doesn't matter what the
damage is done now
how many times have you taken a god
sword if you're decaying or Slayer like
a surrogate saradomin god sword or an
aged yes bgs whatever how many times
have you expect with it and hit maxed or
get close to max most of time you're not
getting that so that that's already V
it's kind of like the the bottleneck for
the Bendel's god so it's value to go up
any any higher than the armed oh god
sword now let's look at the army no God
switchback
like oh god swords the I'm no God so it
has a special attack the judgment in
addition to double accuracy okay so
let's look at the bend it's got two real
quick double that Chrissie okay so the
Bannos consort and the armadale match
that they both double their accuracy and
the AGS inflicts damage with a thirty
seven point five percent or a hundred
and twenty five percent multiplied by
the hidden one hundred and ten percent
every gods or special possesses okay so
it inflicts damage with thirty seven
point five percent higher maximum hit
than a normal attack consuming fifty
percent of the players special attack
energy so this one doesn't reduce any
damage which doesn't reduce any of their
stats whatsoever the AGS is purely a KO
weapon it's its main purpose is just to
kill your target and for beginning
that's that's what you want see in PvP
scenarios the I middle got sword is the
most commonly used as a knockout weapon
because of its massive damage increase I
mean look at this if we look at the
battle squad sort it it only goes up by
21% more damage as opposed to thirty
seven point five and that so the HS is
almost double the bgs is damage buff so
I mean when you guys see people talk
like this I talked about the market
about any item whatsoever
kind of like warning you on what to do
don't ignore them the key thing to being
a merchant and a flipper in this game is
to have your ears open at all times you
know be involved in conversations here
players have to say because if you see
something like this I'm often not you're
gonna have a conversation you're gonna
see other players talk and you're gonna
find another answer other opinions with
it but also more importantly by keeping
your ears open
you kind of get you kind of get like
little bits of information that you
would have never thought about before
so one user was talking about how the
bgs BEC buff might have an impact on
these em rockets or buff
or not buffets its value because if you
have to be just as 50% and there's a
clan Peking another clank another player
could bring his EGS in spec but you know
I kind of thought about that over a
little bit and I thought well you know
they probably just use the IceBridge and
then switch to a b gs anyways they
wouldn't be using both consorts and as
it turned out the CGS hasn't really
changed that much with the update
so looking at the looking at these at
the at this affects everything that
about the battle-scarred it's really an
impaired weapon out of almost all of
them the sizes EGS the CGS is pretty
good for a cool bosses like saradomin
muted all trades or PK if your
applicator but other than that the
dragon Warhammer is still the power more
superior item everywhere the only place
you would actually use the Beddoes god
sword alongside the Dragon Warrior is
Corp with corporal beast you're gonna
want to use both the bgs and the Dragon
Warrior there as well as arc like
because if you've ever been to court you
know that it deals really high damage
and so if you're gonna be Jess Beckett
you're gonna reduce that the damage that
it hits you and if you're using the arc
light does the same thing so you're
reducing them out of the amount of
damage they can inflict on upon you
which makes killing it easier and if you
dragon weimar spec it you've reduces
damage so you make the boss you make the
boss calling easier in a sense and
you're gonna want to use the Dremel and
respect for the pentose cut sword to
reduce its damage so you can hit higher
with the bgs so what else didn't was I
gonna talk about today so okay so we
talked about not being a follower but
keeping your ears open
what else
so I guess one last thing I should
mention is when an update comes like
this make sure to keep yourself informed
meaning read up on the items that may be
impacted so the items in this one where
the AGS band has got sword and dragon
Warhammer those were three items that
people were concerned about now if you
think about the battles godsword has a
peaking item I mean sure you could use
it as a Peking item because it reduces
their stats cooldown quo but how many PK
is going to bounty hunter and use a
prayer pot as opposed to a settlement
brew with a super burst or they're
probably gonna bring both the superb
restore and the saradomin brew alongside
just regular like food so the BG is back
reducing their stats is irrelevant it
doesn't do anything because they're just
gonna drink the restore anyways when
they're prairie goes down a little bit
so you in regards to that you're gonna
want to go for the KO instead but yeah
guys make sure that when when updates
come around because the Dragon Slayer up
to update is coming around
pretty soon and there's there's a few
items that may be targeted and I don't
want you guys to to lose money and I
don't want to I also don't want to kind
of like suggest which items to focus on
which is why I do these videos after the
update has come around I don't like to
do this prior because I mean I want to
have zero influence on what you guys do
in terms of your investments but I want
to help you guys get there when I help
you guys understand my thought process
and how I might do this from from your
position so yeah if this is a pretty
short video but it was also kind of like
a maybe like a little bit of a rant I
guess there's kind of also a market
discussion I think is gonna be really
important for you guys to to kind of
grasp how we kind of read into this kind
of stuff
always always always think about stuff
never never take things at face value
always make sure to read into it do your
research always always do research guys
it's gonna help you in the long run
because with Dragon Slayer 2 pointing
out people may make the same mistakes
that they made with this update so I
don't want to say too much about Dragon
Slayer - because I again I don't want to
influence you guys this opinions but
because if you guys need assistance on
what to do you guys can always review
back to my old guides that I've made on
game updates I made a video specifically
called game updates probably one of the
best videos you guys can watch in
regards this kind of stuff because I go
in-depth in quite a quite a bit of
changes into the game that have affected
items see I make sure make sure you guys
do your research don't be followers be
leaders keep your ears open be involved
in the conversation and if you guys
enjoyed this video be sure to leave a
like comment and subscribe
good luck marching guys and until next
time
[Music]
you